The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: Our topic today
is the influential movement
called Italian neorealism, a
movement of filmmakers that
arose in Italy at the end
of the Second World War
and had-- although it was a
very short lived movement,
lasted only six or seven years
before it kind of dissolved
of its own way.
In part, incidentally, because
although the films were
very successful with critics and
several of the neorealist films
won Academy Awards as the
best foreign film of the year
in 1946 and then again
in 1948 when the film
you're going to see
tonight, Bicycle Thieves,
won the reward.
Despite that acclaim
and even global success,
the movement sort
of petered out,
although its influence as
I've suggested was very great.
One reason the
movement petered out
was that forces in
Italian society,
chambers of commerce
types, people
who are interested
in encouraging
the rebuilding of the
devastated cities of Italy,
a function, a consequence
of the Second World War,
those folks began to feel
that the messages coming
from neorealist films
were too negative
and were discouraging
foreign investors.
So although it was a
very remarkable movement,
it lasted only, as
I say, a short time.
But its influence ramified
very, very, very broadly.
We can trace its influence to
virtually every national cinema
that came after it, and there
are certain very particular
influences that one can trace
from the neorealist movement
to certain American directors
of film noir in the '40s
and early '50s, to certain very
interesting and historically
curious forms of
television that emerged
in the early years of
American television
that were deeply imitative
of and influenced
by Italian neorealist movies.
The man that many would
identify as the greatest
of all Indian
directors, Satyajit Ray,
was directly inspired to make
movies by The Bicycle Thief,
and he made a series of three
films that are essentially
a form of Italian
neorealism moved to India,
a wonderful trilogy
of films, some of them
actually about the
untouchable classes in India,
called The Apu Trilogy.
And they remain among the most
treasured forms of Indian film.
The Italian neorealist
had a profound influence
on other European
cinemas as well,
and most particularly
can be said
to be the originating movement
behind the French Nouvelle
Vague, The New Wave
movement, that in France that
emerges at the end of the
'50s and the early '60s
and it involved
such now recognized,
such directors who
are now recognized
as major figures in
the history of film
as Jean-Luc Godard
and Francois Truffaut.
So it was although a
short-lived movement, profoundly
influential one, and it produced
some enduring, and beautiful,
and I guess I would
say immortal films.
The most famous and perhaps
in some ways the most perfect
of those films is the one
you're going to see tonight,
Bicycle Thieves.
And I'll talk a bit about
that film in my introduction
to the lecture this evening.
I want to begin,
though, by giving you
a sense of how neorealism feels,
a kind of distilled version,
or a distilled embodiment
of many of the deepest
principles of
neorealism, and in order
to do that, I want to show you
a clip from the very beginning
of the film you're
going to see tonight.
So you'll see this
beginning twice.
Hopefully, the second
time you see it,
you'll be alive, more alive
to some of its implications.
So here is the very
opening of Bicycle Thieves.
And one of the things I
want to ask you to watch for
is first how much information,
how much visual information,
dramatic information,
becomes available to you
under the titles, and then how
fluently and fluidly the film
moves out of the title sequence
into a kind of continuation
of the drama that's articulated
in that title sequence.
On the surface,
this little anecdote
at the very beginning of
the film seems very modest
and one might even think of
it as simply expository, that
is providing information
to the audience
so that they can get
on with the story.
As I hope you'll recognize, and
as I'll try to show you briefly
after I've shown you the
clip, much more is going on
than that, and it's a
particularly wonderful example
of the way in which the best
neorealist films generate
a kind of texture, a kind of
density, what I've sometimes
called a multiplicity that we
have suggested in this course
is one of the fundamental ways
in which you can distinguish
between entertainment
and serious entertainment
or between
entertainment and art.
When items and objects begin
to have this multiplicity, when
they begin to serve
multiple functions, not just
a single function, you're
in the presence of something
not only complex,
but something that
acknowledges the complexity
of the world in some respects.
And this opening sequence
of Bicycle Thieves
does this with
remarkable economy.
So here's the
beginning of the film.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
DAVID THORBURN: Great.
Can you freeze it for a second?
One thing I should
mention while you're
watching this, to interrupt
the sequence for a moment.
The activity that you see
taking place under the titles
is supposed to be
confusing at first.
Although, after a while
it begins to clarify.
Perhaps you're not
fully clear what
is going on until
the titles disappear
and you see these men assembling
around that staircase there
where a man with a list
is speaking to them.
What is going on here is what
in the United States in the '40s
and '50s on the docks in New
York, they called the shape up.
And a shape up is
a place where men
who are eager for work sort of
come and hang around and wait
for the boss, the foreman,
or the hiring boss
to pick them out of the crowd.
Shape ups are always
unpleasant experiences
because there are many
people who are excluded,
and the people who
are chosen are often--
this was especially true
on the New York waterfront
in the days which I know
about because my father was
a longshoreman for a while.
It was a particularly bad thing
in the New York waterfront
because you had to know
somebody to get work.
I don't know if that's an
implication here or not.
Although, you'll see as the
men complain that some of them
have that suspicion.
In any case, what's
going on here
is what is called a shape up.
Men are gathered around,
men who are unemployed,
looking for work.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
DAVID THORBURN: I wish I
could let the scene run on.
But I hope you, I hope
you-- I can tell some of you
are responding to
what you saw there.
Make some observations
about what you saw there.
What in that introduction what
do we learn as an audience?
You have to be fast.
I only have a few minutes here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
way for [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID THORBURN: All right.
One thing we know
is that there's
a lot of unemployment in
this country, a lot, right?
And there's a lot of discontent.
And then the minute he says,
I don't have a bicycle,
virtually everyone else in the
crowd says, I have a bicycle.
Everyone is desperate for
a job, not just Ricci.
That's right.
So we learn how grateful he is,
but also how troubled he is.
What's the evidence in the
film that he is really very
unhappy, very, very
troubled by the fact
that he doesn't have a bicycle
to get this job after so long?
What's the most dramatic
piece of evidence
we see that he's
distracted by his anxiety?
Help?
AUDIENCE: He doesn't
help her with the water.
DAVID THORBURN: He doesn't
help his wife with the water.
Yes.
It's a very dramatic
scene, isn't it?
She's walking behind him,
carrying these two heavy--
and he doesn't ignore because
he's a nasty patriarch who
thinks that women
should carry water,
he's so distracted
he doesn't notice it.
And, in fact, he walks
down that little incline
and looks back and sees
her struggling, goes back,
and as soon as he recognizes
it, he takes one from her.
And it's significant, isn't
it, that he takes only one
from her.
They're really partners.
And what else is significant?
She doesn't yell at him.
She doesn't say, my god,
Ricci, what kind of a pig
are you, making me carry
all this stuff by myself?
because she shares his anxiety
and his concern, doesn't she?
So on the surface,
the scenes certainly
dramatizes Ricci's desperate
need for a job and the fact
that he's one of many people
in a similar situation.
But what does it tell
us about his marriage?
On the basis of these
details, what you just
saw in this beginning,
do you think
he has a good
marriage, that he has
a good relationship
with his wife,
that it's a mutually
trusting relationship?
Of course, of course, right?
And how do we know that?
We know that from that detail.
Now, the detail does
not advance the plot
in the sense of telling
us anything further
about his need for the
bicycle or his unemployment,
but it does reveal to us
something about their marriage,
about the kind of man he is,
about the kind of woman she is.
So that it's a moment in which
his anxiety about his job
is maybe the primary
thing we see,
but what is also
dramatized for us
is the nature of
their relationship.
And it's dramatized
for us without anyone
coming out and saying,
let me show you
a mutually engaged couple
who depend on each other
and who survive in
part because they
share each other's troubles.
People whose respect
for each other
is so total that
even when one of them
commits a really mean or
at least an unpleasant act
by ignoring his wife
struggles, she doesn't even
think to complain
to him about it,
because she shares his anxiety.
It's an example of what I mean
by a moment of multiplicity
in which something about
their relationship, something
about their marriage emerges
even as we are also learning
something about the economic
circumstances in which
these characters live.
Say a little bit more
about the scene you saw.
How about the place where
she's drawing water?
What about that?
Why would-- They're in a city.
They're walking, in fact,
to a high rise apartment
house in which they live.
What does it mean that she's
carrying two buckets of water
to an apartment and
then she's going
to climb up four
flights or three flights
to get to their apartment?
What does that tell us
about Mussolini's Italy?
AUDIENCE: There's
no running water.
DAVID THORBURN: There's no
running water in the building,
in the high rise apartments.
And not just that, is
the water precious?
How do you know it is?
AUDIENCE: She doesn't
leave it there.
DAVID THORBURN: Say?
AUDIENCE: She doesn't
leave it there.
DAVID THORBURN: Yes.
But what else?
Where do they get the water?
Is the water-- do they go
to a pop in the open square?
No.
It's in a barbed wire compound.
Again, these details may not
register instantly as deeply
significant, but think
what they tell us
about the conditions of urban
life in Rome in 1947 or 1948
when the film is set.
And you can even go further.
Look more closely
at the setting.
Did anything grow there?
It looked like they were walking
across a wasteland of mud,
except for these high
rise tenement buildings.
So we have high rise
tenement buildings set down
in a kind of desert, a place
in-- buildings that don't even
have running water in which
the main water pump has
to be protected by barbed wire.
So that it's almost as if
in this brief introduction
to the film, the whole
socioeconomic environment
of the story has been
established for us
without anyone giving
us lectures about it
or calling our attention to it.
That's what I mean
by multiplicity,
when the details of the film
serve character and serve plot
and serve our sense
of the environment.
So it's a rich moment.
It's a moment, it's
a moment of art.
It's a moment of complexity.
It's a moment of
human truthfulness
that resonates for us
as the film goes on.
Well, there are many,
many moments like this.
Virtually every
moment in Bicycle
Thieves has this kind
of density or texture,
has this kind of
implication built
into the particular details.
I want to very quickly set
the kind of the context
for-- I've already
implied the context
for the neorealist movement.
The basic context is
the end of World War II.
Most historians
trace the beginnings
of the neorealist
movement to films
that were made under Mussolini
while the war was still
going on, and some
people actually
date the very beginning
of the movement
to a film made in 1942 by
Luchino Visconti called
Obsession.
It's actually an adaptation of
a very popular American pulp
novel called The Postman
Always Rings Twice.
It's been made twice
into an English language
American movie, most recently
starring Jack Nicholson.
But the Italian
version may be the most
important and interesting of
the films made from the book.
The book itself is a
rather tawdry noirish
story about the owner
of a diner who's
an ugly middle-aged pug
who's married to a beautiful
and somewhat younger woman who
very unhappy with her husband
begins an affair
with a drifter who
comes by, and ultimately
encourages the drifter
to kill her husband.
And it's actually a rather
heavy-handed male chauvinist
fantasy about, partly about,
how cunning and dangerous women
are.
The Italian version is much
more interesting, in part
because the working class
dimensions of the story
are given much greater emphasis
in Luchino Visconti's version.
And the film partly becomes
a kind of meditation
on the fate of
undocumented workers
and nonunion workers
in Italian society.
In any case, the emphasis
on ordinary people
and the emphasis on
socioeconomic circumstances
in that film by Visconti
came to be defining features,
among the defining features of
Italian neorealist filmmaking.
But the movement really doesn't
get going until after the war.
And the context of the
war is very important.
We need to recognize
that the film is really
set in a devastated society, a
society in which, I'm talking
now about all of Europe
after the Second World War,
unemployment reached 25% or
30% higher in some societies.
There was economic
turmoil in virtually
every European society,
profound terrible pressures
from black market
activities of all kinds.
The war was so
devastating that something
on the order of 35% of all the
permanent dwellings in Western
Europe were destroyed
during the war.
25% of the Polish
population was killed.
A tremendous proportion,
virtually every-- Well,
a very large number of Italian
cities were damaged very badly,
including, of
course, Rome itself.
And these abject and
terrifying economic conditions
were, of course, in Italy
doubled by the problem
that Italy was on the
losing side of the war
and therefore faced
even more difficulties
in the recovery than a culture
like the French culture
or English society.
So the devastation of World
War II and the turmoil
and the dislocation
caused by World War II
is the fundamental fact.
What is still operative
in Italian society, what
institutions still work, is
one of the implicit questions
that the film explores.
And the film suggests that a lot
of the official institutions,
like the police and especially
the religious institutions,
have broken down and are
not really helping people
very much, as you'll see when
you watch tonight's film.
But there are other
forms of help and aid
that people get, mostly
in some sense from their,
the film suggests, from
their local communities
and from their
immediate families.
Well, to this basic
sort of setting
of devastation and turmoil
and economic uncertainty,
we need to add two other
contextual factors,
both of them having
to do with the film
traditions against which
neorealism set itself,
against which it
understood itself to be
in a kind of profound argument.
The first tradition was the
tradition of fascist film
under Mussolini.
These were almost
all studio films.
They were shot inside studios.
Neorealist films
are shot outdoors.
And they were
largely escapist fare
focusing more often than not
on the upper social orders.
In fact, there was a
genre of films so devoted
to the romantic
entanglements of aristocrats
that they came to be known
as white telephone films.
The reason for this is that in
the old days before cellphones
and before multicolored phones,
all telephones were black.
And it was a mark of astonishing
aristocratic privilege
that the people in some of these
films had white telephones.
They were such unusual
objects for the time
that the film's came to be
labeled as white telephone
films.
And they were
largely, as I said,
escapist movies with beautifully
made up actors and actresses
in artificial light, performing
what were essentially
artificial stories.
The second tradition against
which the neorealists are
responding, against
which they are reacting,
is the tradition of
Hollywood glamor.
There's a wonderful moment
in The Bicycle Thief
as you'll see tonight
when Ricci finally
goes off to get his job.
He recovers his
bicycle from hock.
He's pawned it.
And that's why he's so nervous.
He knows where the
bicycle is, but he
doesn't know how they're
going to get out of pawn.
And you'll see how
his wife solves
that problem in the very next
sequence beyond the one I've
just shown to you.
When Ricci finally goes to
work for the first time,
he has someone with him
giving him instructions,
and what he is a bill sticker.
He puts up posters,
great pos-- In fact,
the poster that
he's putting up is
a poster for an American movie.
And it has a great American,
a famous American movie
star of the '40s and '50s,
Rita Hayworth, on it.
And as he's putting
the picture up--
you put paste on the
board, then you--
he's given these
stupid instructions.
Anyone could do this job, but
the man giving him instructions
acts as if he's explaining
something really difficult
like rocket science,
when all he's doing
is telling him how to paste
a poster up on a board.
But his instructions
include systematic remarks
about being sure not to
leave any wrinkles in it.
And I've taken that myself to
be a kind of implicit complaint
against Hollywood.
They'll say the Hollywood
female has no wrinkles.
The Hollywood female, the
Hollywood star, the Hollywood
movie is so glamorized that you
never see wrinkles or defects.
And this couldn't
contrast more shortly
with the ordinary
faces of the actors
that we see in neorealist films.
So two traditions of
glamor and escapism
are essentially
the antagonist that
help to explain how neorealism
defines itself and understands
itself.
It's worth briefly
mentioning that neorealism
has distinguished
origins in at least three
different national cinemas.
The first is in
Italian cinema itself.
There was a movement
during the silent era,
a kind of documentary
movement, that wanted to talk--
a quasi-documentary movement.
They were still fiction films.
But they wanted to talk
more openly and honestly
about contemporary events
in contemporary society.
And the movement was called
the verismo movement, the truth
movement.
And it occurred between
1914 and 1916 in Italy.
And this--
When the neorealists began to
articulate their own manifestos
and to explain theoretically
what they were up to,
they sometimes reached back
to the verismo movement,
as a way of saying
we're actually
traditional as well as new.
A second fundamental
influence on neorealism,
a kind of earlier
version of neorealism,
occurred in the German tradition
at the end of the silent era
in a series of films made in the
1920s by the director GW Pabst,
P-A-B-S-T. The most famous of
these films is a film produced
in 1925 called The
Joyless Street.
It partly deals with
prostitutes, and it talks,
it tries to dramatize
in realistic ways
the conditions of the
lower social orders.
And of course the final
originating source,
this also explains the
richness of neorealism
that there are other
film traditions that
are feeding in to it and
enriching it, is French,
and it's the kind of
French film that we
associate with Jean Renoir
and with the traditions
of poetic realism.
Some of the neorealist, at least
one of the neorealist directors
Visconti, had worked as
an assistant director
for Jean Renoir at one
point in his career.
And I believe, I'm not
sure this is accurate,
so don't take this
as absolute fact,
but I believe that
it was Renoir himself
who gave a copy of The
Postman Always Rings
Twice to Visconti, which
led to the creation of what
many people would identify as
the very first neorealist film.
The basic practices and
traditions of poetic realism
are carried over in neorealism.
And in one sense, one
can see neorealism
as an extension
of poetic realism.
The difference is
that neorealism
has a more political
and social orientation.
It's more conscious of having a
political and social ambition.
It wants to-- And
sometimes neorealist films
can seem a bit preachy
because of that.
There's clearly a
kind of sentiment
deeply sympathetic to the
lower social orders, deeply
suspicious of the
hierarchies of capitalism.
Some of the neorealists
were Marxists
or Marxist
sympathizers, and that
helps to explain the
political orientation
of neorealist films.
But the basic features
of poetic realism,
the use of an outdoor camera,
the interest in a mise en scene
style, and in a film made by,
which I mentioned I think last
time, made by Renoir in 1935,
a film called Toni T-O-N-I.
We have a French version of
neorealism, because that film,
as I mentioned last time, is
about Italian quarry workers
in the south of France, and it
has a lot of nonprofessional
actors in it, something
that became a key feature
of neorealism.
So the neorealist movement
then has this powerful context
which creates a kind of
moral and aesthetic energy
that helps to explain the
power and the excitement
of these films.
It has two very
clear antagonists,
the glamor of Hollywood and the
false and aristocratic glamor
of the film under Mussolini.
And it also draws as
well on older traditions
of film in Italian, in
German, and in French
that set earlier examples
for the kind of thing
that the neorealists
wanted to do.
I've already talked about the
key features of neorealism
just a second ago when I
spoke about poetic realism.
But let me mention some of those
key features in a little bit
more detail.
One way to think
about neorealist films
is to recognize that
their emphasis on reality
is one which insists
on trying to create
an illusion of a
plausible actuality.
And what this meant
to them was, listen,
people have warts
on their noses.
People are not beautiful the
way they are in Hollywood.
So one thing we need to do
is we need to roughen up
the look of our performers.
And in fact, professional
actors, it was felt,
often bring a kind of
smoothness or a fluidity
to their performance that
is inherently artificial.
So many neorealist films
have no or virtually
no professional actors in
them, or sometimes only
professional actors
in the major roles.
In the film you're
going to see tonight,
the star is a
nonprofessional actor.
He actually ended up
having a tragic life.
The film won the Academy
Award as the best foreign film
of the year in America
in 1948, and the man who
played Ricci became
an international star,
but he fell into hard times
and ended up not really making
much money from his
very brief stardom,
and my understanding
is that he never again
made a film as remarkable
as The Bicycle Thief.
But one of the things
that is absolutely
astonishing about
the performance
is that this man
is not an actor.
You would never guess it.
I mean, it's an absolute--
or maybe you would,
but you would guess it only
after having been told that.
Because he performs with such
naturalness and such grace.
So the use of
nonprofessional actors
is one of the key
features of neorealism.
A second key feature is a
rejection of studio filming.
All neorealist
films, like almost
all poetic realist films, were
shot outdoors in natural light.
Partly because they
wanted natural light,
and partly because studios lie
about the texture of the world.
We want the texture of
the world in our films,
the neo-- Our films are
really about reality,
so we can't shoot indoors.
A third--
nonprofessional actors,
outdoor camera, a
third feature would
be what we might call a
fundamental mise en scene
style, taken directly from the
stylistic habits established
by Jean Renoir and other
French directors who
worked in the same style.
Relatively modest
forms of editing.
The forms of montage that
you see are not disruptive.
You won't get jump cuts
or disorienting moments.
The camera, the camera is,
as with Renoir, constantly
restless and in motion, but
often in very gentle ways.
There's a wonderful
moment in the scene
I mentioned a moment ago
where we see Ricci putting up
his first poster when the
camera is watching them,
and he's getting
these instructions
from his comrade about
how to put the thing up,
and it's really boring.
Well, one reason that you know
it's boring-- well, obviously
as a viewer, you begin
to probably feel it
without registering
that it's boring,
but the reason
that you know it is
is that the camera
suddenly looks away.
What happens is the camera
discovers something interesting
happening on the street
and while the conversation
continues on the
soundtrack, the camera
shifts away from Ricci
and his instructor,
and follows a wealthy
man and two children
who are walking behind him.
And they're really beggars
trying to get money from him.
And the camera just
found it interesting,
so it looked at it, a
very Jean Renoir-ish move.
There are other moves
like this in the film,
as if the camera, like
Jean Renoir's camera,
is so interested in
the world that it's
capable of being distracted.
There's a sense that the
world's complexity is always
threatening the coherences
and meanings that the film is
releasing for us.
So nonprofessional
actors, outdoor filming,
a mise en scene, a profound
serious mise en scene style
influenced deeply
by Jean Renoir,
and finally, we might maybe
another-- not finally,
one more, a fourth
feature, we might say
is what I was trying
to indicate when
I talked about the social or
political bias of these films.
One might say that these
films have a more profoundly
documentary flavor.
I don't mean that we feel
we're watching documentaries.
But we do feel we're
watching a slice of life,
that the economic and moral
and social and personal
circumstances of the characters
we see in neorealist films
are a version of what we would
find if we walked into Rome not
in a movie and just
looked for people
of this class, a
documentary flavor.
So that's four features.
And a final feature, I
suppose I would want to add,
has to do with the relation
between plot and character.
It's not quite true to say
that these films are plotless,
they're not, and one of
the most magnificent things
about The Bicycle Thief is
the economy of its plot,
and I'll talk a bit
about that tonight,
but it's nonetheless true
that in neorealist films,
you do not feel that
action drives events.
What you feel is
that character drives
events in some sense,
what the plot aims
for is a natural unfolding.
You're never supposed to
feel in a neorealist film
that some event in the plot has
been introduced arbitrarily.
You're never supposed to
step back and say, oh,
that could never happen,
or how implausible is that,
or I guess they did that
because they wanted to show x.
The kind of response
you often have
watching certain forms of
Hollywood entertainment
and other forms of merely
escapist entertainment fare.
But you don't ever have that
feeling in a good neorealist
film.
What you feel is that
the events of the plot
unfold naturally out of the
economic and social realities
the characters live in and
out of their characters.
And you can test
this generalization
against tonight's film,
and I'm sure that you'll
find that it's a compelling
one, that it really describes
this movement's respect for
the complexity of character
over plot, for the
complexity of character
and therefore for its
commitment to a kind of movie
that is more
interested in character
than it is in story or
event in a narrow sense.
The central figures
of neorealism
are important to mention.
And maybe especially the fellow
that I have first on my list
here, Cesare Zavattini, because
he's the least well-known
of the names I've listed there.
The other three names
are all famous directors.
And of course De Sica is the
director of Bicycle Thieves,
and I'll talk about his
career this evening.
But Zavattini was the
theoretical genius
behind neorealism and a
figure for whom I still
retain a tremendous
sympathy and affection.
He was a novelist
and an essay writer
as well as a screenwriter.
He collaborated with Vittorio
De Sica on almost every one
of De Sica's significant films.
Not on every one, but
on virtually every one
that is truly outstanding, and
there are a number of them.
He's the scriptwriter on.
And he had a particularly
symbiotic relation to De Sica.
Zavattini also
articulated what came
to be understood as the
manifesto of neorealism.
And in one such
essay, I don't know
if it was titled
Manifesto of Neorealism,
but that was its effect.
He said this to try
to summarize what
he thought the ambitions
of neorealism were.
He said, a good film
ought to be focused
on the life of an ordinary
man to whom nothing happens.
Now, he didn't really
that nothing would happen.
It's not an early version
of the Seinfeld program.
What he's trying to
get at is this idea
that plot does not dominate,
that character dominates,
that the events of the
story grow organically
out of the materials
of the text,
both out of character, and
out of social realities.
So Zavattini was in many
ways a visionary figure,
an overt Marxist for a
good part of his life,
and probably the central
intellectual influence
on the neorealist movement.
Visconti, the
director whose dates
I've put there is sometimes
suggested-- it is often
said that not all of
Visconti's work fits neatly,
maybe none of it fits
neatly into the category
of neorealism.
And this partly has to do
with a kind of flamboyance
in Visconti's visual style,
and maybe also a fondness
for decadence, and for
elaboration that does not
comport with the
social meanings that
are implicit in neorealism.
Of the main neorealists, he's
the one who fits least well,
but he's often said to
be the best of them.
And there are many historians
of film and scholars
of film, including
David Cook, who
believe that The Earth Trembles,
the film he made in 1948,
La Terra Trema,
The Earth Trembles,
is the greatest of
all neorealist movies.
I have sometimes been
tempted to show it,
but it's less characteristic of
neorealism, so I don't show it.
But it is a very
remarkable film,
and Visconti is a very important
figure in this movement,
even though he probably could
be said in his later films
to move beyond
neorealist concerns.
Roberto Rossellini who also
had a very rich long career
as a filmmaker, and I've
only listed one film there,
because I want to show
you a clip from it.
Part of a trilogy
of films he made
at the very end
of the war called,
it was called his Roman
Trilogy or his Rome Trilogy,
and the first one was--
or his World War II
Trilogy-- the first one
was called Rome, Open City,
and then there were two other.
The third one was called
Germany, Year Zero.
And they all had sort of a
political and social ambitions.
They wanted to dramatize
the postwar conditions
and show the devastation
that followed
aftermath, that was the
aftermath of the Second World
War.
Open City had a
tremendous impact
what it was first released,
especially in Italy,
because it told an
anti-fascist story.
It's a somewhat
melodramatic film
that ends in a very
melodramatic death,
in a very melodramatic murder,
or an accidental murder.
And partly for that reason,
it's a less powerful and less
compelling film totally than
something like Bicycle Thieves.
But its importance
can't be overestimated.
It established the
basic principles
that I've been talking about.
It was actually
begun before the war
was over when it was
illegal to-- when
the German authorities,
the fascist authorities
were still controlling
Rome and Italian society.
And you weren't supposed
to-- you couldn't
film without a license, and some
of the early scenes from Rome,
Open City were
actually shot illicitly
on very bad film stock from
behind doorways and around
corners, so the people
behind the camera
wouldn't be caught
by the authorities.
And then the film was
completed after peace came,
after the defeat
of the Axis forces.
I'm going to show you a
clip from that sequence,
from that film, from the
very beginning of that film
to give you a feel for what
the film was like as well.
And I think that that
clip will also show you
why the film was so successful.
But I'll partly explain it now.
I think the Italians
love this movie
because it told a useful myth.
It made it appear that very
few Italians collaborated
with the Nazis and that
most Italians were really
on the side of the
saboteurs who were trying
to blow up fascist waterworks.
This is probably not entirely
historically accurate
since Mussolini was
during much of his career
a very popular figure in
Italy, but you can certainly
understand why it would
have hit a sympathetic chord
among Italians, many
of whom, I'm sure,
felt terrible ambivalence
and shame over the events
of the Second World War.
The Italians were always much
more reluctant anti-Semites
than the Hitler fascists
were, and the story
of Italian anti-Semitism
is much more complicated
than the story of German
anti-Semitism in this period
especially.
So I think that one reason
for the success of the film
had to do with the way it told
a kind of anti-fascist fable
that worked particularly well
for this postwar society that
wanted to put fascism
behind it, that
wanted to repudiate that past.
that felt-- There were certainly
segments of the population
that had never gone along
with that past anyway,
so the film sort of
mobilized a new kind
of feeling of
Italian patriotism,
and maybe even in
some sense a kind of,
despite the
catastrophe in which it
ends, a kind of
hope for the future,
because the film takes place
entirely within the period when
the fascists were still
in control of Italy.
And the catastrophe
that occurs at the end
is an act of fascist
murder, an assassination,
an indifference to humanity.
So Rosselini went on to
make many, many films,
and I feel a little guilty only
mentioning this one not totally
characteristic film
of his, but it's
important in the
history of neorealism.
Rosselini is a
director I much admire,
partly because he moved
away from fiction.
And at the end of
his career, he was
making what he thought of as
educational or instructional
films.
But with the dazzling technique
of a great fiction filmmaker.
So he's a very interesting
figure to study,
and I hope some of you will
look at more neorealist films
and consider looking
at Rosselini.
De Sica is the
final figure that I
want to mention as a fundamental
energy in neorealism,
and I'll only say about
him that he's probably
the most various and gifted
of all the neorealist figures,
partly because he had been a
very successful actor before he
became a director.
And I'll talk a bit more
about De Sica this evening.
What I want to illustrate
now in the time we have left
is an aspect of the
neorealist aesthetic,
if we could use that term,
that I've talked about
before when we discussed
Renoir and that I
implied in earlier comments
that I made this afternoon.
It's what I call the
neorealist counter plot.
And by counter
plot, what I really
want to call attention
to are all those elements
in the film that
seem not to take part
in the forward
momentum of the story.
We might even think
of them as retarding
elements in which these
films sort of pause
to smell the roses.
A version of what
I mean, of what
I mean by this
neorealist counter plot,
might be said to be embodied
in that astonishing camera
move we studied at
the end of Boudu Saved
from Drowning last week
where the camera makes
180 degree swerve,
becomes interested
in the beauty of the
river, becomes interested
in the scenery, almost as if
it's forgotten its character.
Now, what I mean
by the counter plot
is this impulse in these
films and especially
in these Italian
films to complicate
the social and
political and even
the psychological processes
of the story simply
in order to give
us a sense of what
the experience it's
describing is like, as if it's
a version of what I'm interested
in when I talk about how
the camera can distract itself.
One way I can illustrate-- So
what I mean by counter plot
then are energies that retard
or slow down the basic story
or that seem not to directly
contribute to the basic story,
but remain part of the film's
desire to represent the world,
to represent reality and
something of its complexity
and something of
its nuance, even
in something of its
contradictory incoherence.
In other words, I
don't really want
to call these moments
incoherent moments, they're not,
because they build a much
larger and more complete
picture of the whole
world you're looking at.
And in that sense,
they're not incoherent.
But they are a kind of counter
to the ongoing pressure
to find out what happens
next, what happens
next, what happens next.
Well there are
many, many examples
of this principle
in The Bicycle Thief
and in other neorealist films.
But I want to show you one
very dramatic one, also
to give you a flavor
for an earlier
neorealist film other
than the one you're
going to see tonight.
This is from the very
beginning of Open City.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
DAVID THORBURN: These
residents of Rome.
They've heard an explosion.
There's sabotage
going on in Rome now.
It's near the end of war,
and the war's not over.
And now the saboteurs
return home,
and look who they
turn out to be.
And of course, that's why,
Anna Magnani was the actress,
was worried about where
the children were,
because they suspected.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
DAVID THORBURN: There's already
a counter plot operating here.
I hope you see.
Look at these little
chil-- innocent faces.
So these saboteurs
have now come home.
Watch.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
DAVID THORBURN: All right.
Stop.
I'm stopping it a little early.
This scene continues.
You actually go into
another room in a moment,
and you see children
in a kind of dormitory
like room in which there's
one little child sitting
on a potty.
I think it's the first
potty scene in Western film.
They do something
very disturbing too.
They pick him off the potty
and put him back in bed
without wiping him.
But leave it.
Maybe there was no toilet
paper in postwar Italy.
But your laughter
indicated to me
that you sort of got the point.
But talk to me a little bit
about what you see there.
It's a wonderful
example of what I
was trying to illustrate
at the beginning as well,
this principle of multiplicity.
What's happening
in this sequence?
What do we learn?
What about living conditions
in Rome, what do we learn?
Nobody gives a lecture about it.
You think there is a
housing crisis in Rome?
Seven families living together
in the same room, an old man
in bed, lying in a bed, in
the parlor, in the space,
in the living
space of the place.
That's clearly where he stays.
He's very ill.
What else?
The deviation into comedy.
The extent to which a kind of
a series of comic encounters
occur after what, after a
moment of political sabotage.
And the incongruity of
these little children
who are the ones who
are the saboteurs
is also part of the comedy even
before we see them fully return
to the condition of children
when their parents start
slapping them in
the face and say,
how dare you stay out so late.
I didn't mean to suggest
that the parents actually
know that the children are
saboteurs, although, some may.
But I think the point is
that being outside at night
is very dangerous for little
children in this environment,
and that's why
they're so concerned
But the fact that
even the children are
partisan anti-fascist
fighters becomes a part
of what the film is about.
Now, you can't tell
from the very beginning,
from this beginning, what
the real sort of plot energy
of the film is yet, can you?
And it will take a bit longer
before it finally turns out.
The man that she's about
to marry is a secret agent,
and he's under--
he's being hunted
by the fascist authorities,
and the film is
about how the good
Italians try to hide him.
But we don't learn that yet.
What I want to suggest to you
is something of life's variety,
something of life's comedy,
something of life's incongruity
emerges for us in those moments.
It's what I want to
call a counter plot,
because we take delight
in those moments.
We don't get impatient
and say, come on, film,
tell me where you're going.
Because what the
film teaches us is
that it's not in that narrow
sense about plot at all,
but it's about life in
its infinite complexity.
The greatest neorealist films
embrace this principle as well
as any films I've ever
known, and, in addition, they
have a kind of moral
authority that's very rare.
I'm very jealous of those of you
in this course who have never
seen The Bicycle Thief,
because it is a remarkable film
and I'm sure you'll remember
for the rest of your lives.
I'll see you tonight.